as with our population for businesses
large and small coronavirus represents
an unprecedented challenge speaking with
business leaders and representative
organizations every day
I appreciate just how tough the
situation is when we tell people to stay
at home to protect the NHS and save
lives
we know it has a real cost to your
families and to your firms and I want to
thank the many businesses and workers
right across the UK who are playing a
vital role in keeping the British
economy going you are delivering for our
nation through this difficult time and
we said we would deliver for you doing
whatever it takes that is why we have
taken unprecedented action to support
our economy to save jobs and secure
livelihoods to help businesses pull
through at this difficult time we have
set out income support schemes for both
the employed and self-employed as well
as a package of grants loans business
rate holidays and v8e deferrals
businesses and trade unions have
welcomed our interventions and I want to
reassure them that we are working around
the clock to get the funding as quickly
as possible to where it is needed on
Monday we launched the coronavirus
business interruption loan scheme this
scheme is designed to make it easier for
businesses with a turnover of up to 45
million pounds to access vital financial
support so far the schemes 40 accredited
lenders including all of the high street
banks are processing thousands of
applications this week I provided
guidance to English councils on the
grants to our smallest businesses
including those operating in the retail
hospitality and leisure sectors the
first tranche of funding arrived with
English councils yesterday and I want to
ensure that the grant money is with
as soon as possible providing direct
funding support to almost a million
businesses across our country now whilst
our companies have requested financial
support they have also asked us to look
to ease the burden of regulation at this
challenging time and we have responded
to that request yesterday we brought
forward legislation to temporarily
suspend some competition rules in the
supermarket sector and in the operation
of Isle of Wight ferries from retailers
sharing delivery vans to ferry operators
coordinating staff these measures will
allow firms to work together to deliver
vital services to the public more
effectively at this time we've also
introduced measures to ensure that
workers who have not taken all of their
statutory annual leave due to kovat 19
will now be able to carry that
entitlement over into the next two years
this will protect staff from losing out
whilst providing businesses with
flexibility when they need it most
earlier this week together with
Companies House we announced that over 4
million businesses will be granted a
three-month extension to the filing of
their accounts through a fast-track
online process over 10,000 businesses
have already successfully applied for
this extension and we will continue to
monitor the company's abilities to meet
the range of other filing obligations
they have under the Companies Act and we
will provide further extensions if
needed I recognize just how hard
employees business owners and directors
are working to keep their companies
going it is crucial that when the crisis
passes as it will we are ready to bounce
back and so today I want to announce
more measures which are designed to give
businesses and greater flexibility as
they face the current crisis to help
them emerge intact the other side of the
curve in 19 pandemic
we will introduce measures to improve
the insolvency system which provides the
legal options for companies running into
major difficulties our overriding
objective is to help UK companies which
need to undergo a financial rescue or
restructuring process to keep trading
these measures will give those firms
extra time and space to weather the
storm and be ready when the crisis ends
whilst ensuring that creditors get the
best return possible in the
circumstances the changes to the
insolvency regime will include new rules
to make sure companies undergoing
restructuring can continue to get hold
of supplies and raw materials and there
will be a temporary suspension of
wrongful trading provisions for company
directors to remove the threat of
personal liability during the pandemic
this provision will have retrospective
effect from the 1st of March however to
be clear all of the other checks and
balances that help to ensure directors
fulfill their duties properly will
remain in force we will bring forward
legislation in these areas at the
earliest opportunity we will also put in
place measures to ensure that companies
required to hold annual general meetings
can do so flexibly in a manner which is
compatible with the best public health
guidance
this might include postponing or holding
the AGM online or by phone using only
proxy voting in addition we are also
introducing a range of measures to boost
the supply of personal protective
equipment such as face masks to protect
frontline NHS staff and we're removing
administrative barriers to the
production of hand sanitizer by reducing
the amount of red tape new suppliers and
businesses that produce ingredients for
safe hand sanitizer we'll be able to
bring their products to market in a
matter of days companies including
BrewDog and INEOS have already stepped
forward to offer their services
I'm incredibly proud of how businesses
and individuals across our great nation
have risen to the challenge posed by
covert 19 whether it is office from
companies coming forward to support the
ventilator challenge or more than
700,000 people signing up to volunteer
for our brilliant brilliant NHS all
those in the public and private sector
working hard to keep our country safe
and moving Britain is meeting the
challenge working together in a joint
endeavor to get through this pandemic
and be in no doubt the government will
continue to fight tooth and nail to
protect lives and livelihoods everywhere
in this country as we stand shoulder to
shoulder with our people and our
businesses thank you